hundreds of people rallied this week in
st. Louis in a suburb called Wentzville
and they did it to support a display of
the national motto In God We Trust which
hangs in their City Council Chambers
a woman protesting the model was a
school motto was escorted out of the
council meeting last month for exceeding
her time limit but not before she made
her point this has created an atmosphere
of hostility and intimidation toward
those who don't believe in a higher
power I think that is important for
everyone to recognize that woman atheist
activist Sally hunt is here tonight with
her side of the story also joining us is
Missouri State Senator Bob onder it's
great to see both of you
alright Sally let's start with you
because that motto In God We Trust
really seems to send you over the edge
and I want to kind of figure it out the
understanding why you think it's the
establishment of religion in the United
States go ahead well I didn't say that
it is the establishment of religion but
it is certainly the endorsement and the
advancement of religion by our
government so it should send everybody
over the edge if they value the US
Constitution and I do what's very
important to me right which part of the
Constitution do you feel this way please
so the First Amendment Establishment
Clause I which is a very clear and it's
also being well it has been also
interpreted the Supreme Court has also
made it clear if you look up are you oh
are you aware of the lemon test you are
okay so I am Supreme Court no great
great so then that's that's why I would
think that you would also be upset about
the the endorsement and advancement of
religion by our government which is
absolutely unconstitutional because the
motto In God We Trust is about religion
there is no religion
purpose what what we're what does it an
endorse so absolutely Christianity and I
am happy to explain why it's definitely
Christianity okay so because I just go
through for our viewers who don't
understand the Lemon test which itself
is a lemon as Justice Scalia wrote I'm
here the three things that the court
just made up they've made this up and
they just okay this is our test the the
the issue the government action has to
have a primary effect that that neither
advances nor inhibits religion
it can't be an excessive government
entangle in religion either and it has
to have primarily a secular purpose a
government actually paid for by private
money okay this is private money papers
and my question to you is how does this
excessively entangle the government
right in religion which the actions of
the vaunted tests and then we got a good
right so look Laura so the entanglement
part does not have to be part of it it's
there are three parts of the lemon test
and so it has to an action by the
government has to pass each one of those
three
okay so then God We Trust on the coins
is that is that also you have to redo
all the coinage in the country as well
yeah absolutely absolutely that's okay
what institutional okay so the
government the US government the US
House of Representatives congressman
let's get to you on this in US Congress
it has in god we trust' the House of
Representatives George Washington's
great quotes on God and liberty and so
forth you can address you know look a
theists are really unhappy about this
and they want something they sure are
Laura as you know the motto In God We
Trust goes back many years in fact as
far as we know it first appeared in
Francis Scott Key's national anthem and
in 1956 Congress unanimously in both
houses endorsed a resolution making In
God We Trust our national motto and
President Eisenhower signed that into
law and of course we know it appears on
our national coinage it appears in the
halls of Congress both in the house and
then the Senate and in Missouri it
appears in our legislative bodies
and so there's nothing whatsoever wrong
with mayor Guccione and the city of st.
Louis city of Wen's Ville deciding that
they will accept that donation of the In
God We Trust to display for their city
council chambers
in fact senator a lot of other states
are looking at this too because what
happens is you have a couple of atheist
organizations like any time it's like
Easter or Christmas and I said you know
there's a manger scene within you know
500 miles of a public building there'll
be some atheists like oh this really
upsets me we've got to pull it down and
I think that happens is I think what
happens is and so I want to get you in
on this our founding was a founding
based on Liberty Liberty that came not
from the government but for came from
God Thomas Jefferson said 1781 on his
notes on the state of Virginia God who
gave us life gave us Liberty and can the
liberties of a nation we thought secure
when we have removed their only firm
basis a conviction in the minds of the
people that these liberties are a gift
from God Washington of course George
Washington and his farewell address also
invoking God our framers were Unitarian
they didn't believe in like necessarily
organized religion but God was important
so why didn't they mention God one time
in the entire United States Constitution
there's no mention of God there's no
mention of the Bible there's no mention
of Christianity not once but the only
time they mention religion is it to say
that there shall be no religious test
for any elected leader and by the way I
want to clarify why this is clearly an
endorsement of Christianity because so
the Jewish faith says that you do not
print the word God g.od would never be
in the Jewish faith on a sign okay so
it's obviously not the Jewish God so and
then we Hindus believe in multiple gods
Buddhists do not bother you thing that
got your name 22% nobody were secular
people right but but but most
overwhelmingly Americans believe in God
I think it's like 89 percent or do you
send somebody that doesn't matter Sally
Sally I you don't have to scream we hear
you but I think the point is most people
understand that our country was
founded upon this notion of Liberty that
came from on high we are endowed by our
creator with certain in there's no
mention of there's no mention of God in
the entire US Constitution there's no
mention of the legend of my favorite it
was a so it doesn't that doesn't matter
we're taking your ear dirty your liberty
comes from God and the fact that
atheists are so no I also think Sally
like part of it is a lot of is not there
they want to be closer to God but they
don't they don't want to be closer I
don't know what it is but it's like what
does that mean we put what do you pray
for people we pray for people as
Christians I think our friends in the
Jewish faith and the Muslim faith pray
for hearts to change and I think that in
this scenario right you should be
actually atheists actually turn they
turn off a lot of people because it's
not hurting anyone to say In God We
Trust it's it's kind of respectful for
our national tradition do you know duty
and prejudice and discrimination against
refueler people the richest country our
country is particular secular practices
all over the place but government romans
remain neutral
we are neutral we're not endorsing the
Baptist faith by that by looking at that
god we trust' Christianity Laura well
Laura that you know Laura there as you
know that's exactly right
when the Constitution says Congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion an
establishment of religion in its
historical context meant that Congress
would never make America a Baptist
country or a Catholic country or a
Buddhist country but it didn't say that
government has to have antipathy and
hostility for religion and that's what
really Sally seems to advocate wrong
be neutral right now